c'est volontairement de nuit pour que la
zone ne soit pas reconnaissable que
Jérôme André nous entraîne au cœur de la
forêt il faut enjamber plusieurs
ornières marcher à l'aveugle l'endroit
apparaît derrière des fougères ce qui
frappe ce sont ces sacs poubelles
accrochés aux arbres
donc là il y a beaucoup donc de sopalins
mais pas beaucoup de préservatifs ce qui
est embêtant pour nous parce que du coup
il s'est suit avec le sopalin et donc du
coup on voit qu'il n'aide pas forcément
de préservatif ici nous sommes dans une
zone dite de consommation sexuelle entre
hommes elle se situe sur le territoire
de plaisir chaque jour entre 100 et 150
personnes fréquentent les lieux parce
qu'en fait la zone elle va jusqu'à
l'autre bout là-bas rédiger
ce soir là les 45 sont bien remplis au
sol pas de traces d'activités sexuelles
un dispositif mis en place par
l'association HF prévention cela fait 8
ans qu'elle intervient sur ce secteur
c'est une zone qui est très excentrée
par rapport effectivement à la forêt
c'est donc un lieu où il y a donc de la
consommation sexuelle et nous
effectivement on met des sacs poubelles
pour que les gens puissent mettre leurs
déchets préservatif etc directement
dedans ce qui permet effectivement de
garder le lieu calme puisque du coup on
ne voit pas cette consommation sexuelle
si ce n'est avec les sacs poubelles
Jérôme André ne se contente pas
d'installer des sacs à chaque prévention
dispose d'un camping-car reconnaissable
ces animateurs vont au contact direct
des gens pour leur proposer des
préservatifs du gel notamment une écoute
surtout par souci de discrétion nous ne
filme pas ces personnes
bonsoir Monsieur bonsoir On fait partie
de la chef prévention on fait de la
prévention santé et on vient
régulièrement donc sur les lieux et on
propose du matériel de prévention vous
avez ce qu'il faut parfait et puis on
propose du dépistage rapide
dépistage rapide en fait on vous prend
donc une goutte de sang et puis on peut
vous dire donc si effectivement vous
êtes en situation de séropositivité ou
non et c'est immédiat résultat immédiat
en fait les trois quarts des personnes
qui viennent ici sont des hétérosexuels
perdent de famille on a des cadres
supérieurs des CSP++ comme on peut le
dire on n'est pas là pour juger leur
sexualité ou leur dire qu'ils sont gays
ou quoi que ce soit on est là pour leur
apporter vraiment des outils de
prévention de manière à ce qu'ils
prennent le moins de risques pour eux
mais aussi pour leur famille chez eux
puisque effectivement on se contamine en
eux quelque part ils peuvent aussi
contaminer leurs femmes dans le
camping-car offert par la Fondation
Pierre Berger les bénévoles de
l'association offrent donc un dialogue
et quand la confiance est installée il
est possible de pratiquer un test VIH
minutes
donc voilà les personnes qui sont sur
les lieux de rencontre externe sont des
personnes qui n'iront jamais en centre
de dépistage anonymé gratuit et encore
moins en laboratoire pourquoi parce
qu'ils ne pourront pas dire à leurs
femmes qui sont allées en centre de
dépistage ils ne pouvons pas donner leur
carte vitale pour se faire rembourser le
laboratoire c'est très compliqué pour
eux et on est souvent donc le seul
endroit où ils peuvent faire un test
immédiatement sans culpabilité puisqu'on
est dans le non jugement et
effectivement ils peuvent le faire de
manière complètement anonyme et
gratuites il faut
récolter quelques gouttes de sang qu'on
mélangera au flacon numéro 1 qui va
séparer les molécules le flacon numéro 2
qui permet de savoir si le test a bien
fonctionné et le flacon numéro 3 qui dit
le résultat qui précise bien si oui ou
non le test est positif ou négatif et on
le sait tout de suite le c'est immédiat
le résultat est immédiat
un chef prévention est une association
ivinoise devenue nationale elle dispose
d'antenne à Lyon en Vendée dans le
Pas-de-Calais et prochainement dans
l'Essonne et dans le Val-de-Marne sur
les deux départements dont il a la
charge les Yvelines et le Val-d'Oise
l'an passé Jérôme mandré a distribué
35000 préservatifs